hi demarcus
oh you know great thank you for uh doing
this today
we will open for questions first
question kelly eco
hey demarcus uh you know having been out
for a while how do you feel
uh fifth is everything in your body
spirit everything how do you feel
man i feel incredible um you know
being away from the game as long as i've
been this past year
hearing some change uh i mean obviously
it was a tough task
mentally physically but at the same time
i was able to rest my body
and it was much needed rest but uh you
know coming back off of that i
feel incredible my body's in a great
place um my mind is in a great place and
i'm just ready to get back on the floor
and play basketball play the game that i
love
jonathan fagan
hello demarcus welcome we always hear
acl the only rehab that's tougher than
acl is achilles
what have these past two years what have
you gone through to get back to where
you are
held him back but uh you know
i'll be lying if i didn't tell you the
uh the task was tough but uh
you know i think i'm built for it you
know i took it
i took it with a stride and um you know
i just fought through
my will my way through i learned a lot
about myself and
just life in general so uh even though
it was a tough time in my life i'm
grateful for it um
i think i've grown in a lot of areas of
my life
and uh you know everybody's story is
different this just so happens to be
mine so uh
you know i'm gonna grow with the punches
just to follow up you
said you learned a lot what did you
learn i learned a lot about myself
uh i feel like i went through a
situation that a lot of people would
probably gave up or quit and um
you know i just took it as you know this
is my life lesson uh
it's just preparing me for whatever's
next uh life is full of adversity
and uh every battle that you go through
prepares you for the next
so uh that's how i approached it and
also i just want to
i want to inspire the next um i'm not
the only person that's going through
hard times
or that have gone through hard times so
uh and i'm not saying i went through the
worst situation but uh
just when those times come just fight
through not like i said roll with the
punches
thank you mark berman
demarcus how special is this to be
reunited with john wall
man it's an incredible feeling um you
know this is something me and him
have planned and dreamed about for a
long time so uh
i'm pretty sure he's just as grateful
for this moment as i am we're super
excited
um there's obviously a chemistry between
me and him from our college days uh
i mean not only were we teammates
because we've been knowing each other
since we were 14 years old so uh
that's a guy considering one of my
better friends in the nba uh he was
actually one of the groomsmen in my
wedding so uh
you know that's that's a brother for
life so i'm i'm extremely excited to be
on the floor with
what does he bring the rockets on the
floor oh
i mean i mean i believe his gang speaks
for himself for himself
uh he's an incredible town that's that's
a given uh
i think the combination of him and james
that's that's tough for any team to
match up with
pushing at the pace that they play with
the forces they play with their
play-making abilities
they're going to make the game easier
for everybody around them and our job is
to come out there and make the game
easier for them
tim mcmahon
demarcus what do you envision your role
being with the rockets
um whatever's needed uh it's a lot of
different things i can do on the floor
um but me my personal
opinion i just want to come out and like
i said make the game easier for james
make the game easy for john
and the other guys on the floor um those
guys are creating
i know i also had the ability to create
and get guys easier shots so
i think the combination of both of men
as well
and you've obviously played with uh with
anthony davison
uh in new orleans do you not i'm not
trying to compare christian wood but
just as another
kind of multi-skilled big guy do you see
you and wood
as as guys that can play together
absolutely um i was just speaking with
uh c wood about that today i think he
has a lot of
the same intangibles as anthony davis um
i think he has i think he has the
intangibles to be
first team all defense that's something
i was preaching to him earlier in the
locker room
i want to plant that seat early for him
i think i think his mind
should be i want to be the defensive
anchor on the floor every night and i
definitely think he has the ability to
do that
matt muessel
demarcus have you uh have you been
around john at all lately uh
we've heard good reports that he's 100
percent that type of thing
um i haven't been around him lately uh
no i'm
i'm a west i live on the west coast
john's on the east coast you know
obviously there's a lot going on in the
world right now pertaining to covey
but um i mean we talk all the time i've
seen his progress
we've talked about it he's in a great
place physically
and most importantly mentally not only
has you know he battled with
you know in his injury but uh also he's
battled with things in his personal life
so he's also had to overcome a lot of
things
in these in these past couple years so
uh with that being said he's in a great
place he's ready to play ball at a high
level
and i know he's excited to be on the
floor what excites you the most about
this new team they're putting together
here i think we have all the pieces
to make a lot of noise this season um
obviously on paper it looks great but
we have to come out there and put it all
together but just speaking from
that point of view i think we have all
the right pieces to make things happen
um uh
you know obviously james and john with
their play-making ability uh
see wood with his uh with his different
intangibles and his versatility on both
ends of the floor myself with the same
things
uh pj being one of the you know best
defensive guys
in the league uh eric shooting the crap
out of the balls same thing goes with um
you know the other guys on the roster
but uh like i said i just i think this
is the most well-rounded team in
um past couple of years especially since
james has been here
thank you if we can keep to one question
per turn so that everyone can get an
opportunity
brian barefield
demarcus you've been with um two
championship caliber
type teams in the past what intangibles
did you learn or what did you pick up
that you'll be able to bring
to the rockets organization uh mindset
from day one uh that's something i'm i i
know i'm gonna come in preaching i've
learned from some of
the best in the game and uh that's just
something i want to try to break into
this organization
uh a winning mindset a winning culture
um a team first
a team first attitude uh like i said i
think
on paper we have the perfect team to do
great things and uh
i mean obviously it's gonna take us just
putting everything together on the floor
kaylee griffin hey demarcus welcome to
houston
um we spoke to some of the hardships
that you've gone through these last two
years in particular what are some of the
goals that you've set for yourself
heading into this year
um well number one for me is just
remaining healthy
uh i think that's that's the obvious
thing um
it's been a tough road but i'm happy
with where i'm at
uh but the biggest thing is me and
trying to stop being on the same page
with just taking the steps forward to to
be able to stay on the floor
consistently and
obviously the entire season so i think
we got a great plan in place
and uh obviously we just got to put the
work in and move forward
christo staltis hello demarcus
do you feel that your move to houston is
a fresh start for your career
and uh what result will make you
satisfied at the end of the season
i can't quite understand
you feel it's like a fresh start for you
to go
to to play for houston rockets uh
absolutely it i mean obviously it is a
fresh start
i haven't i haven't played a full season
in
almost well two years uh so um
it's definitely a fresh start for me
this is my first training camp in two
years so i'm excited about that
so uh like i said it's just about
putting this plan in place and
following through with adam spolin
demarcus
you talked about you and john have
talked about you know playing with each
other for a while now
what's it like when you found out that
you would be playing together and have
you had a chance to talk to him yet
well obviously it was something that we
were speaking about before the news
you know broke for you guys so um
um it's something that we wanted to
happen and
you know it did so we're excited about
that so uh like i said right now it's
just about putting everything together
marcus um have you spoken with the
coaching staff about your role
particularly defensively and
uh especially with another big here like
christian wood do you and the coaching
staff view yourself as more of a four or
five alongside him
um we haven't we haven't spoken
specifically on that but uh
i mean i can definitely give my opinion
i believe i'll be the guy
guarding the bigger fives and you know
see wood
then a guy guarding the more versatile
uh fours
so uh like that's basically what i was
speaking on earlier about him having all
the intangibles or same intangibles
as in anthony davis so uh i think it's a
combination that can work but
i mean obviously like i said we ought to
put that work in and put it all together
jerome solomon
hey demarcus welcome houston man um you
mentioned
that you look the team looks good on
paper right now we know how important
chemistry is and personalities meshing
how do you see especially the two
particular ball handling leaders in
james and john how they were mesh
coming together um i think it can work
i honestly do um i think john will make
james's job easier he doesn't have to
handle the ball and make plays for
everybody as much as or at the rate he's
done in the past
um maybe so he won't be as gassed at the
end of games or later in the season or
whatever the case may be
so i think with that help and just the
offense culture put into place
um i think the biggest thing is having
fresh legs down at the end of the
stretch and
towards the playoffs so i think it'll uh
play in a positive and a positive way
for us at the end of the day
we have time for two more ben dubose
demarcus you referenced talking to john
a little bit in the last few days but
obviously you
signed or agreed to sign here before
that was
really confirmed what were the other
things about this situation in houston
that made you pick the rockets as
the best fit for you um it was
just that a good fit for me
um i obviously obviously uh
had to check in with the training staff
and see if it was
i in my opinion the best situation that
helped me stay on the floor getting a
better place health-wise and stay in
that place
um you know the coaching staff the
players on the team i think everything
everything that's in place right now was
what i needed so uh
i think it was a great situation
and last one terence harris
taryn hold on can you hear me now
i gotcha okay hey i just want to ask you
what what would how did you find the
inspiration
to kind of keep coming back or you know
after all you've been through these last
couple years
i mean where was the source of
inspiration for you
uh uh i'd probably say it's more so
for my upbringing um i watch my mom work
two jobs for six kids my entire life
so who am i to complain about a little
adversity i've
i've been through things my entire life
i've been through worse
i've i've experienced adversity at an
early age so
working my way through hard times is
something i've dealt with my entire life
so
like i said earlier we for each of those
moments of adversity that you go through
it builds you up for the next
is full of adversity and i'll be lying
to you and myself to think that i won't
have
some type of adversity down the line
another time in my life but uh
me going through the things i've gone
through i will be prepared for it so
that's just my mindset when it comes to
going through a hard time
thank you thank you demarcus we
appreciate your time
thank you